nous vous présentons maintenant une
édition très spéciale de notre journal
télévisé et voici à présent quelques
nouvelles de france il y à quelques
minutes à peine monsieur clampins
secrétaire d'état aux industries
radioélectrique tu a inauguré à nancy la
foire exposition et nous n'avons pas
encore d'image de manifestations bien
sûr mais nous tenons à vous donner
malgré tout une information exacte est
rapide et c'est pourquoi nous allons
entrer en liaison radio avec lucien
gommeux notre envoyé spécial qui se
trouve actuellement à nancy attention
avoue lucien comme eux avouent nancy le
ministre vient de couper le ruban
traditionnel et vétérans vont commencer
les travaux dans le thème central est
vérité de l'information à vous pariez
voilà eh bien nous avons pu entendre
lucien gommeux grâce à de ces miracles
de la technique il était distant de
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
nous et maintenant je voudrais vous
donner quelques nouvelles sportives
incroyable dit dont je viens de voir le
patron qui ma vie qu' il fallait
absolument ce soir avant de nouvelles
très très court garde qu'occupe et
mentionnait déjà sélectionné quelques
heures on va tomber dedans si c'est trop
long parce qu'il faut qu'on fasse très
très très vite
on va essayer coûte j'en ai une qui fait
le ministre de l'agriculture a été reçue
à angoulême
parmi le cultivateur qui manifestèrent
leur violente réprobation oui on veut
dire que raccourcir la dans ce cas m le
ministre de l'agriculture a été reçue
angoulême par mille cultivateurs rice et
voiture a alors atteint c'est la suite
plus tard le préfet régional à démarquer
au milieu des huées des quolibets dehors
devant la gare des manifestants
applaudir les perturbateurs ont pas très
bien si on perd c'est un peu long comme
france n'avait la discothèque tu sais
pas ce qu'on va faire mal être plus tard
le préfet régional a débarqué dehors
devant la gare des manifestants
applaudissent à la salle odyssée pour la
paix oui à tanger un truc là j'ai
monsieur guy mollet a déclaré si demain
le général de gaulle reprend sa
politique algérienne du 16 septembre
il peut être assurés que nous serons à
ses côtés le général de gaulle peuvent
être assurés que nous serons à ses côtés
sa de retour d'amérique le ministre des
finances monsieur gartner a déclaré il
n'y aura pas de dévaluation du dollar
c'est très simple si baumgartner a
déclaré n'y aura pas de dévaluation
modibo kéita déclare ma première
réaction a été vive devant le texte de
2go balle assez facile tu mets ma
première réaction a été vive de gaulle
fit cette fois la journée une qui n'en
finit par la chaînon à la taxe si
l'anarchie persiste à la rtf
le député nungesser déclare que la plus
grande incohérence règne dans les
services les techniciens de la rtf ne
réalisent leurs émissions qu'au prix de
magnifiques tour de force la structure
me naudin termine sur ma m m la rtf
réalise de magnifiques tour de force et
ça va bien c'est le mieux et ça suffit
amplement